four and a half years ago my husband was
misdiagnosed with cancer and this is
that story pitch her this 2012 things
are amazing I had been dating Jake for
about six months and we were obsessed
with each other as young couples are so
we were moving in together and it was
really exciting Jake's mom after a
10-year battle of cancer had just been
given a clean bill of health so we were
all feeling pretty good after maybe a
week of living together
Jake woke up one morning and was like my
neck hurts I was lying down and couldn't
really see him so I was like you've
probably just slept on it funny and he
was like no it feels really weird when I
did look up it looked like Jake had a
literal baseball inside his neck
obviously we were both a little freaked
out I called my dad right away because
he's a doctor he's a gynecologist but
whatever it's all the same I told him
Jake's symptoms and he said it sounds
like it could be mono
so I was like okay maybe that's it Jake
wasn't in too much pain so we decided to
wait a day before seeing a doctor the
next day his neck had only increased in
size instead of seeing a specialist he
decided to see whoever had the soonest
appointment the doctor was like what the
[ __ ] I have no idea you need to go to
this ear nose and throat specialist so
we went and this frazzled little doctor
comes in with like these magnifying
glasses on his head and he's like we
have reason to believe this is lymphoma
now keep in mind Jake's mom had
literally just recovered from the same
type of cancer a week ago so I was just
like nope
I asked the doctor if they were gonna
check for mono and he was like there's
no way there's no need can't be mono cuz
his neck is too big it's a hundred
percent lymphoma so they did a needle
biopsy right then and there
and ran it through a lab while we sat in
the waiting room they finally called us
in and they said the masses monoclonal
so it's most likely lymphoma we just
don't know what type so they referred us
to an oncologist at a big New York City
Hospital Winsett dentally the same
hospital Jake's mom had just been
discharged from the oncologist we met
with agreed that was definitely
presenting as lymphoma I asked again had
they checked for mono I was ignored they
might have well said Lauren the men are
talking I was getting increasingly
frustrated the oncologist sent us to a
surgeon to get a bigger biopsy the
oncologist and the surgeon both agreed
at the rate Jake's neck was expanding it
was an aggressive cancer and we need to
get sample right away since they were in
such a rush
and there wasn't any room in the or they
decided to do the biopsy right there in
the exam room
the next day we came in and we expected
it to just be like a simple snip of
Jake's neck but it wasn't so the surgeon
opened Jake's neck while I sat there in
the room for moral support
but as he tried to get some tissue
something went really wrong it was
harder to get tissue from the mass than
expected and Jake was starting to bleed
a lot for about 30 minutes the nurse
held Jake's neck open with these clamps
while the doctor prodded around he
couldn't get anything and at this point
we were very deep into Jake's neck so
Jake was only under local anesthetic and
it was starting to wear off now Jake
could feel everything the bleeding
started to get so out of hand he needed
to address that instead of getting any
tissue meanwhile I was holding Jake's
hand who was gripping it for dear life
at one point the doctor even had me to
her
not on a cauterization machine because
there weren't enough nurses and japes
legs were like twitching every time they
poked him with the cauterizer they
finally closed Jake's neck but they
didn't get enough of a sample as they
needed so it's basically for nothing we
scheduled a biopsy for the next day in
an actual operating room luckily this
biopsy went smoothly Jake got to sleep
through this one and shout out the candy
crush there gave me through all the
waiting in the meantime since this was
such an aggressive cancer
we were scheduling Jake's first chemo
appointment because of that we had to
free some of Jake's soldiers in case
they got affected by the chemo now we
were very much in love but at six months
we were deciding who his sample would go
to if something were to happen to him
obviously we said me but it's pretty
intense conversation to have so early on
I'll say this if you ever want to know
if you found the one just have a
near-death experience really clarifies
things shortly after the second biopsy
Jake's next start to expand but in like
a new different way it was massive and
like hot to the touch he then got a
fever it was probably around a hundred
at about 10:00 p.m. that night so we
called and they told us to hang tight
until the next morning that night did
not go well Jake's fever kept going up
through the night he was on massive
amount of drug so he kept passing out
every time I was like let's let's go to
the hospital he pass out and then I
check his temperature then I would pass
out and this went on till the morning
we're pretty sure he almost died that
night we went to the hospital the next
day at 7 a.m. by the time we were seen
by the doctor Jake a literally had two
heads the doctor immediately opened
Jake's neck and this next part is not
for the weak of stomach just an
explosion of pus came out of Jake's neck
I've never seen anything like it it was
like liquid vanilla pudding in the midst
of this the doctor asked if we were
married we said we were not and then he
told Jake he better propose after all of
this I actually think after you see the
inside of someone's neck
enough times it's customary to get
engaged so we went back home and Jake
had like a huge hole in his neck and
couldn't lie down because it was
draining and was just totally [ __ ] for
a couple weeks later that week Jake had
a full body MRI they told us his body
was covered in masses we were devastated
we went home and we
for the final biopsy results they kept
pushing Jake's first chemo appointment
back until they found the cell they were
looking for this was three weeks of
changing bandages tons of medicine
basically full-time nursing sometime
during the fourth week we decided to go
out to dinner to take our mind off of
everything suddenly Jake got a call from
the doctor he said they still hadn't
found anything in the biopsy yet which
leads them to believe it's a
non-hodgkins lymphoma which is far
deadlier than Hodgkin's lymphoma I cried
into my enchiladas another week or so
passed and they're running the biopsy
through a second scan eventually we were
called in for a meeting with oncologist
with Jake's first chemo session looming
over our heads then he explained to us
they didn't find any cancer cells in the
second scan but they did find
epstein-barr aka mono it was a huge
relief
we had a new lease on life and Jake had
a giant scar on his neck forever now I
bet you're asking yourself why didn't
you sue being there in the moment I had
no doubt those doctors were trying to
save Jake's life they truly believed he
was about to die it may not have gone
perfectly but they're human and [ __ ]
happens no obstacle seems too big after
you've been through something like that
together we were engaged shortly after
when you feel so close to losing someone
you love you just don't want to waste
any time getting your life started
[Music]